if you were to add up every grain of
sand on every Beach of the world it's
about seven quintillion so bitcoins
running at a hundred and twenty
quintillion calculations per second
taking it over is beyond the reach of
any government bitcoin is changing the
global economy in a profound way that
we're all waking up to right now do you
have any speculations yourself of who
you think Satoshi use people in the
Bitcoin community think of Craig Wright
as a fool let all these guys go at it
let them just figure it out and then ten
years later the government's come over
and they say listen guys thank you so
much for all your help but now we're
gonna take it over that's a 100% losing
bet I would argue that desperation for
Bitcoin is divine
so you think God created Bitcoin it
raises people's consciousness and raises
their character get the pandemic make a
bigger case for cryptocurrency I don't
think they realize that this was the
Godzilla of money this crypto thing is
getting a little too big say the
government comes in hires Max Keiser
I'll put my pinkie in my mouth and say
Oh a hundred million dollars let's just
say the government give you a billion
dollars do it come at me bro so I have
with me today Max Keiser some column was
show them in some call him a genius some
call him a libertarian some call them
all would that be it said max thanks for
being a guest on body Taemin
yeah Patrick great to be on with you big
fan
good to have you on I love when you go
into your friendly heated moments
talking about Jamie Dimon or talking
about your thoughts on Bitcoin you're
definitely passionate and your
perspective is something to think about
so my first question for you know the
fact that look you talked a lot about
Bitcoin you're you're one of those
unique ones that's both Pro Bitcoin and
pro gold and silver the first question I
have for you is did the pandemic make a
bigger case for crypto currency or did
it hurt the argument for cryptocurrency
well you're right I do like both Bitcoin
angle because they are equivalent in
many ways you could argue that bitcoin
is better than gold in many ways and
we've seen
Gold rally we've seen Bitcoin rally the
US dollar looks a bit weak in here and
because of all the money being printed
by the Fed certainly but that's true of
all central banks around the world it's
a race to the bottom to see who can
devalue their currency the most and this
is great for hard assets like gold like
Bitcoin so you're saying the pandemic
actually got people thinking more about
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency than before
well the pandemic triggered massive
money printing and that's good for gold
and good for Bitcoin I think that we're
seeing great mobilization of Generation
Z and the Millennials too into now
investing because they're getting a lot
of free cash from the government and a
lot of that money is finding its way
into Bitcoin the various apps like Robin
Hood and other apps like that
Bitcoin is very native to the
Millennials and Gen Z they they are much
they relate to it a lot easier than they
do gold and so all in all it does have a
positive impact but the trend is Patrick
has been very strong for now 11 years so
that trend is really the primary trend
and the Cobra 19 pandemic is just a part
of the story this year but the fact is
that these central banks have got
themselves caught in a place where they
have to keep printing because of the the
money itself is debt-based money and so
to pay the interest on the debt based
money they have to print more debt based
money it's a bit of a Ponzi scheme and
so that's that trend will continue and
so there is now a growing awareness that
hard assets like gold and Bitcoin or the
place to be
central banks like Russia China and
others have been huge buyers of gold in
anticipation of that point at which fiat
money really starts to lose its its
ability to function effectively in this
economy and the so it benefits both gold
and Bitcoin makes sense I guess you know
the one thing I'm wondering is is there
a way to get data to see if there are
more new believers new users coming in
to buy Bitcoin is there a way to measure
that
yeah sure you have for example cash apps
which is part of square which is part of
Jack Dorsey's business empire he has
both Twitter and square he launched
square launched cash app which allowed
purchases of Bitcoin less than a year
ago and now it's the biggest part of
that business they've sold hundreds of
millions of dollars worth and as a
revenue generator it's I think the
biggest rent revenue part of squares
business we've seen the users of Bitcoin
around the world I think it's now
estimated to be up to 70 million users
and that number is growing
the thing about Bitcoin is that it grows
like a messaging app which is
interesting because messaging apps as
you know from the technology space they
have a period of adoption and then they
hit that hockey-stick moment when
suddenly it's like wow you know we've
got to own this thing and so bitcoin
because it takes advantage of the
network effect that is a technology it
is a network technology so you have that
point and when we get to the big
Buddhists Bitcoin use around the world
as people realize that hey this really
is what people say it is and so that the
numbers are growing rapidly we haven't
yet hit that hockey stick growth moment
yet I think probably we'll see that
pretty soon now you know every time you
know I'm in the insurance business we
were talking about offline I've been at
a financial for 20 years now always when
a new instrument comes out it doesn't
matter what it is you know whether it
was a you know a CDO or whether it was a
every time there's these new products
that come out right and you always go to
who likes it the most who loves it the
most
who what audience does that product the
track and then who hates it the most if
you were to say
who hates the concept of crypto
cryptocurrency who would you say are the
ones that hate the concept of it the
most well we know the detractors of
Bitcoin right now would be the people
who are threatened by it
so the legacy economists like Paul
Krugman Joe Stiglitz Nouriel Roubini
hate it because it challenges their
models that they've been familiar with
for decades we know that banks don't
like it at first Jamie Dimon over at JP
Morgan hated it but now the bank is open
to it he's got relationship style Gemini
in New York which is a huge Bitcoin
player and others in this space so
JPMorgan has kind of flipped over now to
the Bitcoin camp you've got big players
coming in like Paul Tudor Jones he's one
of the biggest hedge funds in the world
for a long time I remember I was
following Paul Tudor Jones when I was a
stockbroker in the 1980s that's how I
got my start in 1983 I was started my
career as a stockbroker was a
stockbroker for eight years on Wall
Street and Paul Tudor Jones is a huge
name and he came out recently and said
that he believes we're gonna see a lot
more inflation now because of all this
money printing he's he wants to bet on
gold but he also has a big bet on
Bitcoin because he says it's the fastest
horse in the race the theory being that
at bitcoins market capitalization can
start to approach that of gold which now
gold is at eight trillion bitcoins at
160 billion so for every dollar move and
gold up you would see twenty-five to
thirty dollars appreciation of Bitcoin
that's what he means when he says it's
the fastest horse of the race
so the those are the people that like it
a lot of people started hating it now
they liked it there was a big community
in the Austrian School of Economics that
at first were not open to Bitcoin gold
bugs hardcore gold bugs were not open to
Bitcoin but every day more of those
people switch over they joined the camp
they understand Bitcoin better and they
kind of join in and appreciate it
obviously one of the most famous I guess
well-known Bitcoin bachelors would be
Peter Schiff
you know he's been you know bashing
Bitcoin
for a long time I've debated a modern a
few times you know I call them the
Bitcoin pinata because you know you can
beat Peter Schiff with the Bitcoin stick
all day long and it just keeps giving
more candy right because his arguments
never hold up the coin when I first told
Peter Schiff about the Bitcoin it was
ten dollars right now it's you know nine
thousand dollars he's been wrong now for
almost ten years and he'll be wrong for
the next ten years the next 20 years the
next thirty years so he's a lot of fun
we like to like to watch them flail
about you know but I think ultimately he
will he will switch over probably
because the market the market is telling
us something Patrick as you know market
signals are very strong you're in the
insurance business or in the finance
business market signals are extremely
strong ways of communicating market
reality right the price signal tells us
what's really going on and the price
signal and bitcoin is telling us that
it's winning against all the naysayers
it's gaining market share it is
equivalent to gold and it's winning over
a huge legions of fans around the world
as the fiat money system is in dire
straits so the timing is perfect so so
that's interesting you're saying that
would with the folks that don't like it
the most because again that gives you
perspective on why there'd be some
pushback from certain areas but then the
other side is also you know who has
really created this and I know what I'm
saying who's really created as we can
tell my Satoshi and all these other name
I'm not talking about that part I'm
talking about is this you know is
Bitcoin cryptocurrency feeding the eye
or the anthesis
and this Isis of the eye meaning it is
if somebody saying hey all of you guys
let all these guys go at it let them
just figure it out let them put it all
together let them figure out all the
mistakes let guys screw the whole thing
up and then five years ten years later
you know the world government the
government's come over and take over and
they centralize and they say listen guys
thank you so much for all your help but
now we're gonna take it over so who is
the who is it is it really the people
doing or there's some people more
powerful than you and I
I got oh behind this right so a couple
of things there first of all the idea of
taking over Bitcoin is you have to kind
of dig into that and understand what
what what those words are implying so to
take over we'll get to that in a second
but let's let's go back to kind of in a
broader context here so the who created
it you know and why did they create it
the history of Bitcoin before the 2009
beginning of it January 3rd of 2009
there's a 20-year history behind it of
the what are called the cypher punks
and these are developers programmers
hackers who were always trying to figure
out what we call digital scarcity and I
myself have a patent on digital scarcity
US patent 595 Oh 176 it's the virtual
specialist technology that is a patent
that covers a digital scarcity as well
as it's the first commercial prediction
market so the prediction market industry
was pretty much I invented that in 1996
and digital scarcity is this idea that
can you create assets digitally that are
scarce in a world of the internet where
everything is basically easily to
replicate you know what we know about
the Internet is that everything's very
easy to copy things that's what makes
the internet the Internet you can send
emails to ten thousand people at a click
of a mouse because it's easy to copy
everything then you create scarcity
digital scarcity and so I know from
experience from my patent and my work at
the Hollywood Stock Exchange which I
created in 1996 we eventually sold that
to Cantor Fitzgerald in 2001 but I know
from my work in this in this space the
limit the difficulty was to come up with
a decentralized digital scarcity which
is what Bitcoin accomplishes unlike
every other attempt is a centralized
digital scarcity and that's not the same
thing so that's that's the first point
the second point in terms of can
be taken over the the fact is that the
Bitcoin network runs at 120 quintillion
calculations per second right now to
give you an idea how big a number that
is if you were to add up every grain of
sand on every Beach in the world it's
about seven quintillion so bitcoins
running at a hundred and twenty
quintillion calculations per second it's
the biggest distributed computer network
ever in history and the cost of taking
it over is beyond the reach of any
government and it's beyond the reach of
any group of governments there is no
entity or group of entities that have
the computer power or the money to
attack Bitcoin in any meaningful way
which makes it indestructible immutable
unsensible and unn confiscate able as
well which is an attribute that a lot of
people are waking up to because it's not
the same with gold
Gold is not uncomplicated ball and
certainly fiat money is not
uncompensated well either so there is no
attack factor coming from a government
there's no attack vector coming from a
group of governments and I would say
that I don't see any attack vector
coming from anywhere at this point
Bitcoin is on a journey to a much higher
prices and changing the global economy
in a in a profound way that we're all
china waking up to you right now now
you've been in the world of finance for
a while so you know the word money
laundering how easy is it to launder
money through Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
and blockchain
money laundering and criminal activities
through Bitcoin is about the worst way
you could launder money because the
blockchain it's open source and
transparent so people that will have
tried to do criminal activities with
Bitcoin get caught a lot easier
well fiat money there is Providence you
have no idea where it's coming from Gold
also it's fungible in that way you have
nowhere where it's coming from the
actual statistic on criminal behavior
with Bitcoin is estimated by authorities
to be less than 1% of all financial
crime lost Bitcoin less than 1%
so so you know you haven't read a lot of
mobsters haven't read a lot of folks who
have let me just jump in for a second if
I may I don't mean to interrupt you
there Patrick but when you talk about
financial criminality and the size of
financial criminality let's remember
that a bank like JP Morgan and Jamie
Dimon have paid hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars in fines for their
financial fraud and their financial
criminality and the the number of frauds
and criminal acts by banks that were
settled civilly with fines if you were
to add that up you know you would be a
guest and and it is it's almost as if
the business model for Wall Street banks
is to keep 90 cents of every dollar they
steal and then they pay 10 cents and a
fine I mean that's where the that's
where the fraud that's taking place
that's their model yeah that is our
model yeah that's right their business
model is from I'm going to even call
that that's marketing dollars if you
want to call it but I'm not asking the
question of money laundering from a
point of trying to corner you or the
industry of Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
I'm asking it from the standpoint of you
know when things eventually get
centralized and you get people that want
to come and take over they find them in
right they look at an angle and they say
this is how we're gonna come in so you
don't you don't worry that the
blockchain world is going to attract the
more criminal activity and they're gonna
come through and try to figure out a way
to long their money you don't worry
about that just to be clear there is no
centralization of Bitcoin and there is
no ability to centralize and there's no
ability to centralize Bitcoin it's it's
a it's a mathematical impossibility
it's like saying you're gonna stop the
Sun from rising in the east tomorrow by
stamping on the ground and crying right
can you unpack that on pre-k because the
protocol of Bitcoin is this brilliantly
balanced protocol of what's called a
consensus algorithm and that all
elements of it are balanced in basically
what you could boil down to being game
theory there's there be incentive for
everyone involved in the network is to
let everyone else involved in the
network balance their incentives in such
a way as to resist censorship because if
there was a censorship involved and the
value of the coin
a hundred fifty sixty seventy billion
dollars would be threatened so it's
there's a game theory that's baked into
the Bitcoin protocol that resists any
attempt to centralize it and you know if
there was any ability to centralize it
or have influence on it in a meaningful
way we we would have seen by now after
eleven years since it does threaten all
central bank's and it does threaten all
fiat money we would have seen some
success or hint of any success in that
direction but so far we've seen
absolutely none because for the reasons
I outlined the cost is too high nobody
has the money to centralize it and
nobody has the computer power is
centralized it and certainly not a group
of two-bit mobsters they do not have the
ability to centralize it if you want to
take a bunch of Wall Street banks and
European banks they don't have the money
or the or the capital and no government
has the money or the capital it's this
is decentralized digital scarcity built
on a protocol that it was birthed in
2009 and has now been established as
creating absolute scarcity which is
something that even gold can claim you
know goal is not absolutely scarce gold
is relatively scarce but it's not
absolutely scarce so you have a store of
value a store of wealth distributed
demonstrating absolute scarcity that you
can use as a store of value as money
available to everyone on the planet
that's why you know you're getting a lot
of pushback from governments you know
because they realize that this is a
direct threat to the central bank model
of centralized fiat money printing but
just to be clear the the point is that
the way the technology is constructed
let me put it this way
the internet runs on the tcp/ip protocol
and it's completely distributed and it
would it would be extremely difficult
bordering on nearly impossible
so ball for one entity to centralize the
internet the Internet the virtue of the
Internet is that it's distributed that's
what makes it the Internet
if you start to balkanize or to
centralize the Internet so all parties
attached to the internet have an
interest in keeping the Internet
decentralized if that's why it's works
the same thing as Bitcoin everyone
invested or part of the Internet
Protocol which is this distributed
protocol like the TCP IP Internet
Protocol they it's it's it it Foster's
decentralization that's the definition
of what it what it's all about and so it
resists centralization and therefore we
we'd I don't put that as a an attack
vector or a threat in any meaningful way
well I mean let me take a different
angle bin let's play a game of devil's
advocate you're familiar would Frank
Abigail right yeah you've seen the movie
catch me if you can right so say the
government comes in hires Max Keiser
they give you open check you know give
it a hundred million dollar check they
say hey max we need your help this
crypto thing is getting a little too big
and we need to take control of it we
need to figure out a way to regulate it
what is the angle to take to get in
there regulated and take control of it
well you know like the Austin Powers
movie you know I'll put my pinkie in my
mouth and say oh a hundred million
dollars right the the Bitcoin network is
100 million is not enough let's just say
the government give you a billion
dollars well what I'm saying is that no
government has has the budget for this
they don't have it there's no government
has a budget for it now let me explain
how this works a little bit more so
let's say the budget was a hundred
trillion dollars right which is which is
which is the global GDP is about 70
trillion dollars and the stock market's
worth roughly thirty trillion corporate
bond market let's call it ten trillion
okay so let's go big let's say let's say
you're gonna give me a hundred trillion
dollars to go after the Bitcoin protocol
Bitcoin well this is what happens the
the the protocol sniffs out that there's
a hundred trillion dollar player that's
now attempting to stage a takeover and
centralization of the protocol so two
things happen
number one the calculations per second
number starts to skyrocket because the
only way to have any impact on this
protocol is by actually mining you know
by actually creating or doing what's
called a 51% attack on the chain so that
means you're from 120 quintillion
calculations a second two to three four
hundred quintillion calculations per
second so that means that the price
which follows the hash rate or the
calculation rate would go from the
current value of practically nine
thousand for Bitcoin to go to two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
four hundred thousand dollars per
Bitcoin you know heading to a million
dollars a Bitcoin so the more you attack
it the the higher the price goes and the
more expensive it is to attacking that's
one of the genius elements of the
protocol it actually invites people to
attack it the way that they see the
network stays secure and the reason the
price keeps going up is because every
month or two months somebody shows up
and says I'm going to attack the Bitcoin
network I'm gonna be a player I'm going
to attempt to centralize it and of
course that's exactly what it wants it
attracts that kind of interest and that
increases the calculations per second
which increases the security which
increases the price and that price means
it's drawing from the fiat world more
people are saying wait a minute why do I
even own fiat money when I can be owning
this Bitcoin and it's going up a lot why
do I even own gold when I could be
owning Bitcoin and it keeps going going
up a lot so you know have at it throw it
throw one hundred trillion dollars at it
you know do it you know I want to see if
it can go to a million dollars so you
know come at me bro so you're saying
there's no way even if they get even if
they hired the best person that knows
everything about the game
even if they hired you know Craig right
they brought anybody and you're saying
there's no way in the world to stop the
momentum being created in crypto or
blockchain correct it's it's it's no way
it's it's a first of all you mentioned
Craig right there Craig right is a known
fraud so we should make that clear
so we shouldn't mention him in any
context of a serious conversation but
the the the point if the bottom line is
that's exactly that is what I'm saying
that it's beyond the reach of any
centralized group authority or
assemblage of money or technology to
stop Bitcoin it is now a runaway freight
train it is basically the way the
protocol works in a lot of ways Patrick
is that it has an insatiable need for
energy because all that calculations
calculative power needs energy and
bitcoin is becoming the biggest energy
user in the in the world it will soon be
the single greatest use case for energy
all energy in the world because I'll
give you a give you another interesting
story that's developing I know your
background I know you're Iranian it's
interesting that Iran is now mining
Bitcoin and because they see that they
don't want to expose themselves to the
US dollar they want to escape the US
dollar and the way that the US dollar is
used politically by censoring the Swift
dollar mechanism etcetera you know
Iran's been sanctioned and they do so
using the dollar so Iran was it's been
been pretty you know hip to the idea
that you know what we can actually
escape the US dollar hegemony around the
world by starting to get into this
Bitcoin so now what this will do is
naturally other countries like the US or
the UK will look at that and say wait a
minute
do we want Iran to potentially be the
richest country in the world because
they would have the biggest Bitcoin
position in the world no we don't want
that so now we're gonna get into the
Bitcoin mining it'll be like when Russia
launched the Sputnik satellite in the
early 60s it launched a space race right
America said we can't let Russia you
know win the space race so then they put
all their money back into space
exploration and we know the story there
so now that Iran has tipped their hand
and said we're getting into Bitcoin
which is the hardest one he ever known
in the universe and we could potentially
have the hardest money on planet Earth
and potentially be the richest country
on planet Earth these other countries
will say wait a minute no we're gonna
get into the game so they're gonna
devote all of the you know energy
budgeting and capital to Bitcoin mining
and what's what I would call a hash war
or a Bitcoin mining war which i think is
that what we're gonna see in the next 12
to 24 months this country is competing
with each other to accumulate as much
Bitcoin as possible and then that will
drive again the hash rate or the
calculation per second rate higher which
would drive the price higher so you get
that price will constantly be going
higher so I think that is what more
likely outcome then then the outcome or
the idea that somebody's gonna decide
that they're gonna try to control
Bitcoin that that's a losing bet that's
a 100% losing bet so let me ask you what
you know why'd you make the comments you
made about Craig right I know in the
past he's claimed that he's Satoshi and
he's the one that owns the Genesis block
and you know I don't know whether he
lost the private key or not why did you
say what you said about Craig right it's
so well documented now very well
numerous sources that his claims are
bogus
and he also is behind a competitor to
Bitcoin or he's part of a competitor
Bitcoin called Bitcoin Satoshi vision
which is an outright the fraud as well
and pretty much he's been called at
numerous times he's launched several
Lost
that are all either lost or in the
process of losing and their D has no
basis whatsoever to make those claims
he's been it's been shown that they
claims are baseless and the way he
thinks and the way he talks in the way
he conducts himself is would be kind of
if you're trying to create a character
of somebody who knows nothing about
Bitcoin who is the antithesis of the
character and the vision behind it it
would be someone like Craig Wright it
was he's a fool I mean the people in the
Bitcoin community think of Craig Wright
as a fool basically as a fool he has no
credibility whatsoever in the Bitcoin
space he's absolutely laughed at and a
year or two from now we you won't hear
the name will be forgotten forever
who else has claimed that their Satoshi
outside of him nobody nobody's ever
claimed that's right interesting
do you have any idea yourself is there
anybody in the community when you talk
to you so you know you kind of have an
idea how this whole thing who who was or
no it's still something that's unknown
it's unknown and it's better than its
son now tell me why because if you have
a known person attached to it they
become an attack vector and people will
attack that person and they and so you
don't want that you want you know who
invented gold yeah this is different no
they're good at all is different than
them bitcoin dog then cryptocurrency no
well how's uh how's goal created through
what what creates rail through the
creation of 13.8 billion years ago the
Big Bang and Universal started elements
collapsed stars exploded that's the
point it's not man-made you know gold is
not man-made
bitcoin is kryptos man-made it's
slightly different you know it's a I
would argue that
eration from for Bitcoin is divine and
that it reflects it it reflects an inner
divine nature of humans so it is similar
to gold in that way if you believe that
God
created everything including gold and
you would also believe that God created
Bitcoin so you think God create a
Bitcoin do you think God do you think
God created gold
I don't think man created gold well do
you think God created man good that is
the agnostic position let's just say
there is a creator yeah so and
everything in creation goes back to the
Creator that would include I can't say
God created a car I'll make a but the
reason I say that the reason I say that
is make that position is because the I
realize that it's a it's an interesting
position but it's also yep the effects
that bitcoin are having on the world are
quite interesting and that is bringing
about a realignment of the way people
think about themselves and about their
economies and about their communities
because for example Bitcoin encourages
people to save money which is different
than encouraging people to spend money
it's like when you know you have I'm
sure that as part of what you are doing
over there your company and you talk to
your employees and things like that you
know one of the ideas you want to get
folks to understand is do not go too far
into debt don't over consume be self
sovereign be your own person have inner
strength and morals and values and then
those values are carried over into your
work and your family and your community
and so you know you can't do that with
fiat money because fiat money is
inherently debt based money and the more
you they issue the worse the economy
gets and it's extremely a poor system
whereas gold you know people who who buy
gold and store gold they have a kind of
a different attitude toward I cravings
okay so Bitcoin bitcoin is the same age
technology Bitcoin is the savings
technology that changes people and
profound ways they think differently
about their communities about themselves
it has a very positive effect it's a
it's passive resistance you're opting
out of the fiat money system and you're
now saving Bitcoin it's like you would
save gold and you look at the
Millennials in the gen Z and
like you know this is actually in a
world with leaders are corrupt and
mentors are not available and the
business establishment is run by people
of dodgy character you know I'm finding
my my inner kind of strength by saving
and achieving individual sovereignty and
I'm doing it through Bitcoin so that's
why I say it has a celestial or divine
quality about it because it makes people
it raises people's consciousness and
raises their character and that's an
important thing that for folks to
understand it's part of the process of
maturing right you know you have to you
have to take the responsibility for
yourself now you know I know you say
that you've said you've never sold a
Bitcoin before everything you bought
you've kept right now that's not
everybody do you know that the
marketplace of Bitcoin and crypto has
had the reputation of also attracting
some dodgy people too I mean you can see
a lot of different series and
documentaries and 60 minutes on it but
going back to Satoshi just out of
curiosity you don't have any comments on
that so you say first of all there
there's Bitcoin and then there's the
crypto market trip no crypto is is
Bitcoin there's Bitcoin and then there's
5,000 other failed attempts to compete
with Bitcoin there's like there's gold
then there's pyrite there's fake gold
right there's attempts to be goal
Bitcoin is there's only Bitcoin there is
no actual crypto industry it's only
Bitcoin that's the industry and then
everything else is junk and [ __ ] it's
not serious in any way so I just want to
make that point so so do you have any
speculations yourself of who you think
Satoshi is or not at all you don't put
any thought or energy into it well I
know the people that were involved in
the cyberpunk movement who contributed
different parts to it right for example
in the white paper dr. Adam back has
mentioned he is a cryptographer and he
has been active in developing the some
of the elements that went into the
ultimate protocol the ultimate creation
so he's a big part of
hal fini is somebody who was a big part
of it he talked you know there's some
great chats and gone on in chat rooms
before the launch and al fini he's no
longer with us anymore he died sadly and
there's three or four other people that
you could say are part of direct you
know directly part of it I think you
know my view is that you know Patrick in
industry in in business a lot of times
you have like an industrial accident
like the creation of microwaves or
penicillin or nylon you know these
things that come along that they were
viagra was supposed to be hypertension
medicine you know that's not the market
for viagra today right korto
you know bitcoin was the purpose of
Bitcoin was to solve what's called a
double spend problem or to create
digital scarcity is another way to put
it and it's a very specific objective
and I don't I don't think the people
really ultimately wanted what it was
appeared I don't think necessarily they
realized that this was like the Godzilla
of money really that it was going to
challenge the global economy the way
that it is right that's a bit of an half
of it was engineered half way I think
was just accident it's just this yeah
it's just a brilliantly engineered
brilliantly incentivized protocol that
solves a very specific problem but in so
doing has changed the world I don't
think that was the intention really I
think the intention was just to solve a
very specific engineering problem and
like many industrial accidents of the
past it changed the world you know
something is the creation of plastic was
an accident and yet you imagine our
world today without plastic so in in
essence it's an accidental currency is
what you're saying
yeah it's an accidental money you know
it's a furnace anything can be currency
but there's only no money only money can
be money so so let me ask you this let's
transition to a complete different side
and then I want to kind of get your
thoughts on a current times Trump the
Trump is publicly not been a fan of
bitcoin is that a fair assessment with
Trump where he stands with that sure
okay so now Trump has also got a method
of the way he negotiates he's he's a
power player he's somebody that'll
freeze assets he'll somebody that'll put
terrorist you know somebody that push
people to run you know somebody that you
know will play every single power play
in the book of power place right if he
gets reelected and he wants to go
through his power plays and somebody can
use through bitcoin to transfer money
and there's not an ability to freeze
assets do you think a Trump getting
re-elected is that a good thing or bad
thing for the cryptocurrency world or is
it irrelevant it's irrelevant in a lot
of ways because no government as we've
talked about has the power to stop
Bitcoin or any group of governments you
know the question is comes up a what if
governments you know outlaw Bitcoin what
happens then nothing because the Bitcoin
is uncomplicated well for one thing it's
it's it's unsensible and it's not going
to be plus all these government
regulators and politicians are paid and
fiat money right so you know every
revolution what happens is the
regulators and government officials end
up becoming a Fifth Column
you know during the revolution because
they they kind of sell out the
revolution inside and you see that with
any any governments that try to go after
a Bitcoin there's gonna be plenty people
in that government we're gonna be buying
Bitcoin because they're being paid a
fiat money and the fiat money is
collapsing you know it's the story of
the Roman Empire right they try to pay
their soldiers and ever diminishing
amounts of silver until they soldiers
started you know working with the
Vandals and they and and the barbarians
this is the Saint gonna be the same
story because the bitcoins hard money
and fiat money is not hard money so that
that's just not a threat it's not an
attack vector it's not a threat vector
and plus we had now have plenty of
Bitcoin billionaires and multi
billionaires who have true
this lobbying influence in Washington
okay and well either direct billionaires
or associate or affiliated with billion
billionaires so Peter Thiel for example
is a billionaire he's part of the PayPal
get a mob as they call it you know and
and so he's got tremendous influence at
least I know he did a couple years ago I
believe he still does then you have just
a lot of other folks in that circle that
have you know billions of dollars and
they haven't the ability to change laws
you know America is kind of one of the
cheapest countries in the world in terms
of graft you can get a law changed in
America for a hundred thousand bucks you
know it's I wish our senators were more
corrupt and that they would cost more to
change laws or or to create new laws to
tell you the truth but they seem to be
open to pretty nickel and diming you can
get a lot changed in a heartbeat this is
why you know the financial sector they
overturned every single regulation since
1933 1934 the Securities Act you know
well because you took a series 7 exam so
you know those those laws every single
thing in that securities law Act of 33
and 34 s been overturned by lobbyists
from Wall Street in Washington so now
none of those protections exist anymore
and we have a situation that we have now
that they just try to meet every single
problem by printing money the money's
being debased
it's backed by nothing or as Paul
Krugman of the New York Times says the
u.s. dollar is backed by men with guns
okay great well if you can't pay the men
with guns anymore what happens to your
currency because you know
hyperinflationary collapse to zero so
you know this is this is the sad state
of affairs that fiat money is not going
to breed a solid political economic
class representing solid values that
people are going to look up to know it's
disintegrating before our eyes
Patrick it's disintegrating before our
eyes and I cannot believe the fact that
people don't care what else constantly
printing money mother was just pathetic
to me that it just keeps happening over
and over know
we keep talking about how quantitative
easing is not the way to go but we keep
doing it over and over again the last
whatever 15-20 years let me ask you a
question you're in the insurance
business okay it's all works on spreads
sure it has to go to negative interest
rate so what happens to your industry
you already know what happens too many
insurance carriers many insurance
curious cannot be accepted more business
if they go that route okay
well you know why they do negative rates
because they're bailing out corrupt
banks no one else using that it's
pathetic right so so I'm saying Bitcoin
is you know get your 50,000 agents to
start selling Bitcoin what are your
customers a favor turning around let's
turn it around Patrick I'm gonna make
you a billion dollars I've got two ways
to make you a billion dollars number one
put Bitcoin into the mix of products
your agents are selling number one
number two I've got an idea for an
insurance product that'll make you a
billion dollars and I hope you remember
me by giving me a commission when you
catch that billion dollar checks so so
let me ask you if if we know what
direction Fiats going and you have
really you know a couple different
choices right let's go back to gold
standard hypothetic Lucas you go to go
back to gold standard it's gonna be
pretty ugly you're gonna have to get a
lot of people to buy in a country could
do it but other countries don't mind
it's just a technical move to make to
get the world to be comfortable with it
and then again when America needs money
when we have to go off a gold standard
so what are somebody sitting there
saying you know what look I'm with you I
understand the fiat currency is backed
by nothing it's imaginary
I trust you just take care of me I'll
take care of you it's fine wink wink
what is the alternative to protect
ourselves from this constant
hyperinflation taking place what are
some of the alter I know you're gonna
say yeah Bitcoin but what else are some
other ways somebody that's also with has
the same fears of fiat currency what are
something they can do look people are
comfortable with gold to some degree
gold and silver then Gold's made new
all-time high 'aa gainst every currency
in the world just about except the
dollar so you know it's made huge moves
and you know in these countries that are
being
that are collapsing the pheno fiat money
is collapsing in a lot of countries
right now
silver obviously is you know in the same
boat as gold it's it's a store of wealth
and you have Bitcoin the thing about
some of these other traditional store of
value or store of wealth or it's gonna
be a problem like property for example
property I would imagine you're gonna
start seeing property taxes you know
skyrocket because all these government
giveaways they got to pay for it somehow
so we know taxes are gonna go a lot
higher and property taxes are gonna go a
lot higher so I think property is a bit
of a problem you know in the stock
market it's you know it's kind of
interesting in that they're the those
companies that are really software based
where the scaling of those enterprises
it's just a matter of adding a server
and you add another five million
customers or what have you I mean that
that is gonna still be an interesting
model so square is interesting I
mentioned the you know I mean not not to
get I'm not making a recommendation here
okay I'm not giving a financial advice
but a company like DocuSign which is
just you know get stolen
yeah they digital designing and
documents over the use them we became a
lot of money every month yeah exactly
okay they are a public company and
they're growing like a wheat and as
everyone is kind of champed out in their
home you know sheltered or whatever
business goes on and you got a sign you
gotta sign deals and if you can and you
don't go to the office to sign a deal
you do it on DocuSign so that that
business is moving up companies like
Shopify which enables people to set up
shop on Amazon that's doing very well a
company like elastic which is the AI
that a layer that runs under a lot of
these software apps on the web is a
tremendous business
it's a various kind of a new business
you know these are kind of new
businesses and again I'm not giving
financial advice and I'm not I'm not
recommending these I'm simply pointing
out instances where even in a collapse
of fiat money and a collapse of the
economy you could see it's the
some growth in these types of relatively
frictionless businesses again with your
business you know not to not to be you
know pick on Patrick that David today
but you know you've got a lot of people
they've got to go out there and talk to
other people right you know that's that
the scaling of that business is
different than a software business where
you just plug in a server and now you've
got another million users right you're
on
it's an asymmetric battle you know for
us it's so amazing what this pandemic
did ninety percent of our sales were
face-to-face max 90 percent pre-pandemic
was face to face during the pandemic
last month we saw ten thousand nine
hundred and sixty eight insurance
policies and I'm not talking about term
or final expense I'm talking real life
insurance policies it was the biggest
month we ever had by four thousand
policies and it was a 90% done through
zoom so it completely changed the game
for us as a company as an industry let
me ask you technical that's great you
know that's actually that could be an
interesting point right because people
are maybe hesitant about having a
face-to-face meeting but what do you
call so that we're not expecting this
are investors but thinking we're gonna
lose 40% they flat-out told us say we're
thinking you're gonna lose forty percent
I'm like okay let us see what we're
gonna be doing and we make some
adjustments you know for somebody like
mice okay I'm talking to a lot of
different people on the Bitcoin side and
a cryptocurrency side
I keep hearing blockchain everybody
knows blockchain everybody keeps hearing
about blockchain but then you're hearing
about Oracle then you hearing about
chain-link right you keep hearing these
three different words can you break down
how they all work together and why it's
important to start paying attention to
chain-link with people saying that we're
gonna get to a point where you know
there's gonna be technology linked to
your car that's gonna feed data to say
how many speeding tickets you get how
fast you're driving and that data can be
used what do those three things have to
do with our everyday lives that we live
in why should we know about it all right
so you remember during when the internet
broke in the mid 90s and there was
concern that it was too decentralized or
it wasn't appropriate for corporations
so they developed the the Internet I'm
the intranet yeah right so companies
would have their individual
company-wide Internet and they call it
an intranet and that's like blockchain
essentially anyone can start a
blockchain and it's it's a way to it's
just it's software and it's a way to you
know manage data and but it's not it has
nothing to do with Bitcoin Bitcoin uses
a blockchain in the protocol but in a
decentralized way using a proof-of-work
algorithm that is unique and separate to
Bitcoin anyone can use a blockchain so
if you're talking about let's say
blockchain as a business tool well you
know there are a number of businesses
that rely on logistics and rely on them
heavily obvious like a FedEx or a UPS or
Amazon the synchronization of their
supply chains can be improved with a
blockchain because you know blockchain
would give you greater visibility into
the synchronisation of your supply chain
and do so using software in a relatively
efficient cost-effective way and going
forward it's going to be obvious to more
and more industries that using that type
of technology is going to be beneficial
you know that kind of triggers another
thought here which is that the history
of Commerce in America in a lot of ways
do you think about how software has
transformed every industry in the world
over the past 30 years right every you
know the airline industry is really
software business the car industry is
really software business every industry
is both is reliant on software really
today that's where they get their
margins right they don't get their
margins out of stamping metal and
sticking it together and selling a car
really the margins are and the ability
to synchronize and distribute the supply
chains and there's some efficiencies
over that and then that's how they kind
of get their their their margins so the
only industry really or the only aspect
of the of our business world going back
a hundred years or more the only the
last thing the last man standing was
really money itself you know money had
been kind of the same for more than a
hundred years you know you go to the
central
thank you stick in a bunch of cotton and
ink and you print up some paper or the
central bank digitally will you know
they'll create digital money as they do
that's a relatively modern thing but it
had not undergone the transformation
that software has transformed in every
other industry every other aspect of
modern life until Bitcoin so Bitcoin
essentially is that wave of software
transformation that hit everything else
you know money itself was kind of the
last thing and now now it's been
conquered the money is now being been
conquered essentially it's now gone to
Bitcoin is now is now money so that
that's that's kind of another way to see
how what's happening historically and
what how it fits in to commerce and I
think also going forward you have you're
gonna see a lot more micro payments
involved in in the in the economy so
instead of subscribing to a content
we're paying $80 or $90 a year for that
content you'll be paying you know a
fraction of a penny per article that you
read etc and then by far the easiest way
to do that or the cheapest way would be
Bitcoin I think Twitter is going to
start allowing people to tip other
people on Twitter using Bitcoin so if
you like a tweet of mine you can you can
give me one one hundredth millionth of a
Bitcoin which is called a Satoshi there
and you can tip me in this way and you
know this is done because of the
efficiencies the cost efficiencies of
basically software as money so that
that'll be a big change and so that
that's where I think we're and I think
ovid 19 and the lockdown and all the
changes that we're seeing or just
accelerating that that that change you
know it's really fascinating what you
said about zoom and your business
because you know all those people are
now completely literate when it comes to
using video software on their phone and
using apps on their phone and now
they're gonna go to Robin Hood app
they're gonna start using Bitcoin but
people in Robin well anyway I don't
myself so yeah go ahead so that that's
my answer
yeah so again
just like you said a [ __ ] you know a
Bitcoin became a accidental money I call
the accident accidental currency we
accidentally became virtual doing
everything on so by the way any thoughts
on the Bill Gates a pattern pattern on
the cryptocurrency chip that he's
working on do you have any feedback or
thoughts on that or opinion on that well
it's again it would be centralized right
it's only valuable to Microsoft if they
centralize it therefore sonic
competition to Bitcoin
you know because anything that's
centralized wouldn't be competition you
know he's trying he's as I understand
that patent and it's kind of interesting
is I own a patent as I told you on the
virtual specialist technology which is
used in hundreds and hundreds of
instances primarily by banks to trade
derivatives because derivatives are
virtual securities and so my patent
Allah gives them a way to trade virtual
securities with a digital currency so
that was sold at Cantor Fitzgerald in
2001 and then they license it out to
banks around the world to in the
backbone of the really the global
derivatives industry which is a an
interesting market trading phantom
securities but that's another discussion
but you know what's Bill Gates as I
understand it he's he's the patent
allows for energy collected from the
human body mmm
to mine Bitcoin essentially from using
your own body's energy as an energy
source or in mining a cryptocurrency I
should say and so that is an interesting
philosophical question because it would
mean that individuals would be not only
self sovereign but they would be able to
become economically sovereign simply by
the conversion of the neurological
activity in their brains which would
have some current some electrical value
into a currency of some type I think
that's kind of what the patent says so
that the average demand that sounds
crazy about the way max I mean who do
you know that sounds insanity well
that's what that's what they be a patent
as I read the patent but I mean report
the whole the idea of patents is I use
trying to you know
most patents don't really get realized
right I mean so people come up with lots
of different ideas when I created the
virtual specialist patent nobody thought
that virtual currencies and virtual
securities that nobody thought that was
a good idea
now you can't imagine by the way any any
feedback on the stable coin the whole
you note either being the first stable
coin you know what are your thoughts on
that
it's a tool used in the industry a
shuttle value around it's just like a
money market essentially and you know
that it's just a part of the swing of
stuff that goes on it's not only asked
because you see some time when they
print more a bunch of teether you see a
Bitcoin going up and you you know you're
kind of seeing those two go together
is there any effects cause an effect
that we should know about the two that
with tether you know there is a lot of
kind of canoe supply of demand they
create a lot of demand let's say with
tether but that the demand is coming
from many different sources and on any
given day you could point to any
different one of these things as being
the primary demand I think right now the
biggest demand for bitcoin is coming
probably from Barry Silbert
over there at his company in New York
City which is he has a kind of an ETF
that he trade grayscale it's gbtc is the
symbol and he I think he's buying up
depending on how you do the analysis
between a half and a hundred percent of
all new Bitcoin coming into just as he's
buying them out right for his clients so
his institutional demand for bitcoins
he's a huge driver right now of Bitcoin
I would I think I think Paul Tudor Jones
and the hedge fund community is going to
emerge is I think at this time next year
Paul Tudor Jones will be kind of like
the king of Bitcoin I think he'll have
them more Bitcoin than the Winklevoss
twins they'll have more Bitcoin than
anybody real quick series of question
yoo-hoo-hoo collapse first u.s. or China
or neither
they'll be coterminous coterminous okay
30 seconds max who were you in high
school I was in high school with you 16
years old who was max I had my own TV
show in high school I was doing the
exact same thing I have marked our TV
our high school had a closed-circuit
television network and I had my own TV
show in high school I mean exactly the
same person same person have you were at
16 exactly we'll ever have a third party
president well we have a libertarian or
independent president anytime soon I
think the US government will collapse
first before we have any third party
candidate how soon is the collapse by
the way your opinion it's tied to the US
dollar and the US dollar is toast and
that's being played out right now how
are you processing everything that's
going on right now would be fun in the
police to rise to protesting the media
all that division that's taking place
today in u.s. it goes back to having
values having strong values you know I
take a lot of strengths from reading the
classics you know going back to
Aristotle played on a sacred sacrifice
and reading classics because it's all
been this is not new well history
repeats itself and empires come and go
and you know this is the the ancients
had the wisdom and go back to the their
wisdom and it you know it becomes my
wisdom and you have to be circumspect
and take a step back and have faith that
the universe will provide
right the universe will provide I don't
need to meddle with the universe the
universe will will carry on I just need
to listen and be part of it and and and
know that it's gonna work all good
speedrun I'll give you a name tell me a
one word that comes to mind I'll give
you a word tell me I'll give you a name
tell me one word that comes to mind
satoshi nakamoto anonymous John McAfee
fraud Ron Paul sincere Peter Schiff
misguided Donald Trump disco what was
that discount okay
Jamie diamond sociopath
Putin statesman really okay Jack Dorsey
visionary Zuckerberg rich he is David
Solomon from Salomon Brothers yeah no no
no response okay
Buffett overrated Nassim Taleb irascible
Ray Dalio overrated overrated okay
Bernie Sanders maple syrup Michael burry
from from Big Short yeah not interesting
okay Jerome Powell quantitative
knucklehead Venusian smooth operator and
last but not least Jared Kushner lucky
duck lucky duck huh lucky duck max it's
been a pleasure having you on value
Taemin where can people find you just
pray and I appear you pray and you
appear with your Bitcoin in your phone
we're gonna put all the contact
information below for guys to be able to
find your max once again thank you so
much for being a guest somebody taemin
my pleasure helps to do it again
sometime say it Patrick this is by far
the most in-depth interview I've done on
the topic of blockchain cryptocurrency
Bitcoin and we went very deep and I want
to hear your thoughts what you took away
from this but I would tell you this if
you enjoyed this interview the complete
opposite of this interview would be with
Peter Schiff who is a former economist
very similar to max but they have
different opinions so if you want to
kind of hear the interview
with Peter Schiff I did a few weeks ago
click over here to watch the interview
and if you've never subscribed to this
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care well bye
[Music]